how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to another episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where you all
submit your theories to me I choose five
to go over each week and then you all
vote on your favorite one to win the
overall monthly prize congratulations to
all of last month's winners there'll be
a video coming out soon so you can all
vote on which one you think should win
the overall month and the prize if you
would like to submit your own theory for
a chance to end up an episode you can
find the email to send them to and the
instructions in the description down
below
okay so let's dive into some theories
we've had a lot of new footage come out
since the last Theory Thursday so these
are really exciting theories the first
one comes from Kyle and Brian la savita
and it's really simple but I really like
it
Kyle and Brian say that the Avengers may
not initially intend to go back in time
we know that they're going to go and
search for Thanos in the beginning of
the movie and they think that the
Avengers are actually going to defeat
Thanos but right before they kill him
Thanos uses the time stone and sends
them back in time each individual
Avenger to a different timeline this is
an interesting theory because if you
think about it Tony Stark and Scott Lang
ant-man are not on the Bennet are in the
scene in the new footage where the
Avengers are going to find a nose and we
know that it's going to be primarily
Tony Stark and Scott Lang that make the
quantum realm suits and the Russo
brothers continue to state that we have
no idea what is going to happen in
Avengers in game and there are supposed
to be a lot of twists in this movie and
this could definitely be a huge twist
that the Russo brothers would definitely
throw at us it's a way to have
time-travel involved in the movie but
not in a typical way and then it would
be up to ant-man and Tony Stark to go
and find everybody this could explain
why there are set photos of Tony Stark
and ant-man who look like they're from
the future and Captain America who is in
the past so although I think this would
be crazy to see I wouldn't put it past
the Russo brothers so that's it for
theory number one ought to theory number
two number two comes from art in the
great and he has a theory about what
rocket and Thor are looking at and the
new special.look trailer ardan says that
in this scene it looks like rocket and
Thor are looking at something gold and
he thinks that they are in the same
place where Doctor Strange got the time
stone because of the way that the floor
looks were rocket is standing ardan
thinks that they are looking at the soul
world's entry because the soul world is
gold and they look happy and surprised
Arden also thinks that either Captain
Marvel or the Hulk will go and look for
Valkyrie in the rest of Asgard because
Thor knows that they're out there they
could help them in the battle this is
actually a really good thought because
we do know that the soul world is going
to play a part in Avengers in game the
Empire magazine article came out and it
actually mentioned the soul world and
that perhaps the quantum realm is a way
to access the soul world but Wong is
still alive and he could still be at the
sanctum where Doctor Strange got the
time stone and perhaps Wong is in some
sort of communication with Doctor
Strange and that's their way to access
the soul world this is a very logical
theory and something that I think could
be expected to happen in Avengers in
game so that's it for theory number two
on to Theory number three theory number
three comes from Mason McDowell and he
thinks that beta ray bill could make an
appearance in Avengers in game Mason
says that beta ray bill almost had
cameos in thor ragnarok
and the guardians of the galaxy but
ultimately Kevin Feige decided not to
put him in the movies because they
thought it was too quick and didn't do
the character justice and the Russo
brothers have expressed that they want
beta ray bill in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and in thor ragnarok his face
is on the Tower of Champions so it is
confirmed that he is in the MCU but we
have yet to see him on screen so Mason's
theory is that after the Avengers go and
fight Thanos in the beginning and lose
the Avengers will go back and try to
move on with their lives as best as they
can after the snap four goes off to aid
the remaining as guardians and finding a
new Asgard and in their travels they
come across a planet that is suitable
when they land they come face to face
with a monster beta ray bill and Thor
immediately goes to fight this monster
who was instantly hostile towards the
people landing on his planet and the
monster goes toe-to-toe with him
equalling him in strength they
eventually come to a standstill and then
Thor begins talking the strange creature
down from its rage and begins to explain
what's going on beta ray bill then
discloses that phantos destroyed his
planet and has banished him to the
planet he's currently on with no other
intelligent life because Thanos felt as
if beta ray bill could possibly pose a
threat to him beta ray bill ends up
joining the fight against Thanos at the
end of the movie The Avengers have
defeated Thanos but Thor has died in
battle and beta ray bill has survived on
the ground life Stormbreaker with every
other avenger unable or unwilling to
pick up the weapon bait
bill feels drawn to it and picks it up
without a problem thus Stormbreaker
becomes his this is something that I
would love to see in avengers endgame I
would love to see batery a bill
officially enter the MCU and Kevin Feige
and the rooster brothers have all said
that they do want him to appear in the
MCU could the timing be right to
introduce him in Avengers in game Kevin
Feige has actually said that there will
be characters that we haven't seen in
the MCU yet in Avengers in game from the
comics and technically beta ray bill is
the first one to wield storm breaker in
the comics so this would be a super
awesome way to tie him into the MCU and
bring him into Avengers in game so that
does it for theory number three on to
theory number four theory number four
comes from Gunther s and he has a theory
that the snaps split the universe in two
Gunther said that the snap didn't kill
everybody
it literally split the universe into the
dusted members all saw the opposite set
of characters get dusted as the two
universes were splitting apart which
means that there is now a universe where
the og Avengers were dusted but
spider-man and Doctor Strange are alive
during the snap the mine stone gave fan
Jose how to for a do-it-yourself
universe split the reality and space
stones were used to create the two
universes the soul stone was used to
ensure that everyone survived being
ripped into one universe or the other
the time stone was used to ensure that
everything was able to continue to
function without time being disrupted
the kicker is the Power Stone which
Gunter thinks they nose used to split
himself into two as well and the
gauntlet and the stones that is why
Thanos is weakened and disoriented and
that is why the gauntlet was damaged
after the snap it's also why he will be
a totally crazy person an in-game
ant-man was protected by the snap from
being inside of the quantum realm which
he learns allows him to travel between
the two universes Scott goes to the
other universe to talk to Hank and Janet
to get the blueprints for the suits then
he goes back to our universe to get
everyone to work together to bring the
universes back together
that's why Thanos attacks that's why
everyone is marching together and that's
what the new suits are for and then when
the universe comes back together
that is what unlocks the dormant mutant
gene and the people who will become
x-men this is a pretty crazy theory but
it does have its merits after all
Thanos kept preaching mercy and
salvation throughout Avengers infinity
war eliminating half of the universe
isn't exactly a mercy or solve
so maybe something else happened after
all his plan didn't really make sense he
could have just doubled the resources so
perhaps instead of killing everybody he
simply sent them into another universe
and the way Gunther lays out what each
individual infinity stone does does make
sense so perhaps we'll find out in
Avengers in-game that there was a little
bit more to thanasis plan than we
actually know so that does it for theory
number 4 on to the last theory number 5
theory number 5 comes from Mike King and
he has a theory about who the 2nd
villain in Avengers in game could be
Mike believes that Thanos looks into the
future and sees the oncoming worst
villain mentioned as the new threat vana
starts to build his new army against the
Avengers and Captain Marvel and the new
threat Adam warlock so the new villain
is finally Adam warlock and he comes to
earth seeking the guardians of the
galaxy tracking down the benatar but
they're not there and instead he finds
the Avengers and Captain Marvel The
Avengers fill Adam warlock in on what
has happened and Adam agrees to help
them undo the madness and together they
go after Thanos once Thanos has defeated
Adam warlock agrees to take the Infinity
Gauntlet and starts the infinity watch I
think everybody would absolutely love if
Adam warlock came into Avengers endgame
he was mentioned in the post-credits
scene for guardians of the galaxy vol 2
however James Gunn did say that Adam
warlock is not going to appear in the
MCU until guardians of the galaxy vol 3
but Marvel does say things just to throw
us off and James Gunn is a producer for
Avengers in game Adam warlock in the MCU
is supposed to be designed to seek out
and fight the guardians of the galaxy so
it makes sense that he would track down
the benitar to earth however I'm sure
when he hears what Thanos has done he
would be more than willing to help the
Avengers to feed Thanos especially since
the guardians of the galaxy aren't there
with the exception of Rocket which I'm
not sure Adam warlock would really care
about a talking raccoon too much so that
does it for this week's theories for a
theory Thursday be sure to vote on which
one you thought was your favorite let's
do a quick recap theory number one is
that the Avengers go and fight Thanos
and right before they're about to defeat
him Thanos sends them back a time at
different points using the time stone
theory number two is that rocket and
Thor and the new special.look trailer
are actually looking at soul world and
are in the sanctum sanctorum with Wong
Theory number three is that beta ray
bill will make an appearance in Avengers
and game and fight alongside
The Avengers Theory number four is that
the snap actually didn't kill half of
the population of the universe but in
fact split the universe into two and
theory number five is that Adam warlock
will make an appearance and Avengers
endgame and help the Avengers fight
Thanos so that does it for this week's
theories be sure to vote on which one
you thought was your favorite and again
if you would like to submit a theory of
your own for a chance to end up an
episode of Theory Thursdays you can find
the email to send them to and the
instructions in the description down
below make sure you subscribe so you can
stay up to date with all episodes of
Theory Thursdays and so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame and Marvel I hope you
enjoyed this week's episode of Theory
Thursday and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof I like this one
[Music]
you